so I'm afraid right now on the stage I
feel fear in my life I met many people
that will readily admit when they are
afraid and I think that's because deep
down they know how easy it spreads see
fear is like a disease when it moves it
moves like wildfire but what happens
when even in the face of that fear you
do what you got to do that's called
courage and just like fear courage is
contagious see I'm from East st. Louis
Illinois that's a small city across the
Mississippi River from st. Louis
Missouri I have lived in and around st.
Louis my entire life well Michael Brown
jr. an unarmed teenager was gunned down
by police in 2014 in Ferguson Missouri
another suburb but north of st. Louis I
remember thinking he ain't the first and
he won't be the last young kid to lose
his life to law enforcement but see his
death was different when Mike was killed
I remember the powers-that-be trying to
use fear as a weapon the police response
to a community in mourning was to use
force to impose fear fear militarized
police imprisonment fines the media even
tried to make us afraid of each other by
the way they spun the story and all of
these things have worked in the past but
like I said this time it was different
Michael Brown's death and the subsequent
treatment of the community led to a
string of protests in and around
Ferguson in st. Louis when I got out to
those protests about the fourth or fifth
day it was not out of courage it was out
of guilt see I'm black I don't know if
you'll notice that
but I couldn't sit in st. Louis minutes
away from Ferguson and not go see so I
got off my ass and go check it out when
I got out there I found something
surprising
I found anger it was a lot of that but
what I found more of was love people
would love for themselves love for their
community and it was beautiful
tell him police showed up then a new
emotion was interjected into the
conversation fear now I'm not gonna lie
when I saw those on the vehicles and all
that gear and all those guns and all
those police I was terrified personally
and when I looked around that crowd I
saw a lot of people that had the same
thing going on but I also saw people
with something else inside of them that
was courage see those people yelled and
they screamed and they were not about to
back down from the police they were past
that point and then I could feel
something in me changing so I yelled and
I screamed then I noticed that everybody
around me was doing the same thing and
there was nothing like that feeling so I
decided I want to do some more so we're
on my thought
samih artists I make sure so I started
making things specific to the protest
things that would be weapons in the
spiritual war things that would give
people voice and things that will
fortify them for the road ahead
I did a project where I took pictures of
the hands of protesters and put them up
and down the boarded up buildings and
community shops my goal was to raise
awareness and to raise the morale and I
think for a minute at least it did just
that then I thought I want to uplift the
stories of these people I was watching
being courageous in the moment and
myself and my friend and still make
important to side-by for the idea just
that without documentary who streets
I kind of became a conduit for all of
this courage that was given to me and I
think that's part of our job as artists
I think we should be conveyors of
courage and the work that we do and I
think that we are the wall between the
normal folks and the people that use
their power to spread fear and hate
especially in times like these some will
ask you
Yatta movers in the Shakers know the
thought leaders what are you going to do
with the gifts that you've been gigging
to break us from the field advise us
every day because I'm afraid every day I
can't remember a time when I wasn't but
once I figured out that fear was not
putting me to me it was there to
protect me once I figured out how to use
that fear I found my power thank you
[Applause]